Good morning Hank it's Tuesday, May 3rd, 2016
I gotta go vote, walk with me
Just an absolutely beautiful day for an election
Done and done, the best part is you get a sticker
You'll never guess where I'm going next
That's right Hank, in a stunning turn of events I find myself in an airport
*'No Smoking' announcement in Spanish*
You know my number one complaint about the Indianapolis International Airport...
...which I truly do believe to be the best airport on Earth
Every 12 minutes...
I mean, at what point in human history is it just presumed that you can't smoke in an airport
I think that point is in the past
On the other hand, I guess if it weren't for that message I would be pretty happy
just to live he rest of my life in the Indianapolis International Airport
and maybe that's what they're up to
maybe they're trying to get me to actually get on a plane.
Today's video, comes to you in 4 very special parts
Part 1: Voting. I already did that
Part 2: Hank, today is also my Dad's birthday which I guess means it's your Dad's birthday
Lots of people don't know this but our Dad basically ran our company until a year ago
He did like all the payroll and budgeting and spreadsheets that made Crash Course and Sci-Show possible
He's also a really great Dad and person - Happy Birthday Dad, I love ya
Why's it so easy to say, 'I love you' to my parents when I can only say it once a year to my brother on, 'Esther Day'?
Anyway, Part 3: Racing
So, Hank I'm going to be driving the 'pace car' on May 14th at the 'Angies List' Grand Prix of Indianapolis
I was very excited about this because I'm a big fan of Indie-Cars
But then, I, ah went to the track and I tried, I, uh, did my practice
I thought that being the 'pace car' driver was like a purely ceremonial position
You know like running with the Olympic Torch or being the Prime Minister of Putin's Russia
But it turns out, no, I have to drive the car, at what is for me, very fast like 110 mph in the straightaways
Oh and I'm very scared, if you watch it on TV just remember I'm doing my best
Part 4: Speaking of crashing, God I hope I don't crash, Crash Course
Hank, here in the United States, millions of high school students are taking their AP Tests right now
This is always great news for Crash Course: our views sky rocket!
Anyway, I just wanted to take this opportunity to say to High School students, doing well on tests is great but it is not the point of life
or the point of education
Tests are a somewhat inefficient way of measuring your understanding of, like, life, the universe and everything
But the point is not to do well on the test, the point is to have a more engaged  and fulfilling life during this
your one brief flicker of consciousness
So, Good Luck and study hard, but not just for the test.
Part 5: Did I say there were only gonna be four parts?
Do I contradict myself? Very well then, I contradict myself.
I am large, I contain multitudes
Right, Part 5 is my beard
Hank, as you may have noticed
I have shaved
I didn't shave for six consecutive weeks because
AFC Wimbledon, the 4th tier English soccer team sponsored by Nerdfighteria
just kept winning!
And it got to the point where I was pretty desperate to shave but I also
wanted AFC Wimbledon to make the playoffs
because if they made the playoffs, they'd have a 25% chance of becoming a 3rd tier English soccer team
And it's always been my dream to sponsor a 3rd tier English soccer team
And then, Hank, the most amazing thing happened!
First, AFC Wimbledon lost a game, allowing me to shave, and then
another team didn't win a game, allowing AFC Wimbledon to make the playoffs anyway!
So good luck to AFC Wimbledon
If they make it to the finals, Hank, I am going to Wimbly stadium to watch the game
Also Vice Sports made a great documentary about the team and my relationship with them
So check that out
Part 6: Last part I promise.
Vidcon! Nerdfighters if you want to participate in the si-
*No smoking announcement in Spanish*
I know I can't fumar!
If you want to participate in the signings and meet-and-greets you have to register by May 13th
so fair warning
Alright the no smoking messages have gotten annoying enough that I'm going to get on the plane.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.